[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
and we are live yet again with the 2020
candidate tournament here on chess.com
the one and only grand master robert
hess alongside me danny wren
we're getting set for round five and uh
i'm as excited as i always am
at 4 am on the west coast robert an
early start but
little has changed in a day and that's
because there were four draws
yesterday there are some fighting games
for sure but the results have stayed the
same so as we head into round five
of the 2020 candice and we see these
really heavyweight matchups particularly
this game
between anish giri and fabiano carwana
danny
i think today we will see some results
that are
not just draws what do you think of this
matchup gary garwana
i mean at this point three of the four
rounds have been that way i'm expecting
the players to continue to play
fighting chess you mentioned yesterday
at the end of the show you think yuri
will come out
with a solid approach that was a
politically correct way to say he
doesn't want to lose
to the man he probably considers to be
the strongest in the tournament fabiano
caruana but
i'm going to guess that the the guy with
the white pieces in the the second
matchup we're going to talk about
alexander grisham versus dingley wren he
might come out with a little bit more of
a
you know what i feel like i've been
denied four times here i want to get my
full point
uh and maybe that offers daily ransom
when he chances with black
yeah that's an interesting take because
gushing has to be frustrated
with his games thus far he drew the
first three rounds from superior
positions
yesterday he won the think tank for
seemingly no great reason he criticized
himself actually
in this post-game interviews so for
grishop with the white
pieces he should stabilize he should
look to uh try to play
another good game against dingle wren of
an opponent who is extremely tough
but i think stylistically for sasha is a
relatively good matchup
in the sense that they both are
precision players
so it's who is having the better day
will come out on top
alex cenko plays maxine vashtay the grav
his lowest rated player in the field
gets the white pieces against one of the
leaders in the tournament
so this will be an interesting one to
see if alexander who also hasn't had
many opportunities with white this will
be his second chance in five games
uh like uh like yonder pomnyashi but
we'll see we'll see how that goes i
think if you're maxine vashti the grav
you're
you're excited at the opportunity to get
the lowest rated player in the field as
a tournament leader right now regardless
and uh you know maybe alexenko pushes a
little bit too hard as well
the last and fourth final matchup we
haven't talked about yet is actually
yonda pomneyashi
and uh his battle coming up with wong
hao now this is this is probably
the the critical match-up of the round
if you're talking two tournament leaders
yan getting only his second white in
five games i can't wait to see what this
one brings us
this one promises to be a bit of a brawl
because
janupamashi he's in the lead right now
but i just something that feels like
he's a tiger
waiting to be unleashed because
yesterday against five minute caruana
he played an extensive amount of theory
and
he was in a slightly worse position then
when bishop was on we were talking about
how
all of a sudden he was turning the
tables trying to play for the upper hand
it was a draw there was no
real danger for fabinho caruana in that
game against yon
but it feels like jan's in great form
right now
and it'll be interesting to see how he
starts his game against wong hao
also is in good shape yeah i agree i
think that of all the players so far in
the event
yan has probably played the best chess
overall i think we both sort of feel
that way
let's talk about where the standings are
at though because even though he maybe
he has played the best chess he's still
sharing the leaderboard with two other
players maxine vashey the grav and wong
hao all with two and a half out of four
you get that middle of the pack carwana
grishak they've gotten there in
different ways
fabiano having both won a game and lost
a game in the event so far
but alexander grisham drew all four
we've got anish geary dingley wren and
alex cenko all with one and a half out
of four
those guys those guys are going to have
to start looking to make a move here at
some point
given that uh if the tournament gets too
far and they still haven't managed to
get a win
they're going to see the leaders
separate themselves even further so
on that note the games have begun i
pulled up alex senko's game with vashi
the grav because i'm hoping to see
uh you know what you know what i'm
hoping to see that's the uh the
some of the sharpest sicilians known to
man and we'll see if we get a night off
here and uh whether carrill
wants to challenge mvl in his uh in his
wheelhouse
well hopefully it's not too sharp i
don't want you cutting yourself it's an
early morning
out there where you are and so we we
want to you know get things settled
before we play
you need some sleep sir that's why i
shave before bed though you take a
shower before bed
rather than you know you don't you don't
shave at 3 in the am it's just not a
good idea
well i don't know what i don't think
you're
full of good ideas so i'm not going to
get into that right now but danny what i
want to get into is this sicilian from
the white side of creole alexianco and
this move
f3 here because very common
against a6 you see a bishop
move right bishop g5 bishop e3
or bishop e2 or bishop c4 right those
are the four i would say
main moves for white after a6
so either the light scored bishop or the
dark square bishop developing instead he
chooses
f3 which in many ways is a flexible
approach
asking black to make a choice of his own
is nbl going to play
e5 and be left with that d5 weakness
or is he going to play e6 and that
covers the d5 square which is always an
issue in night orbs but
is a little tamer a little more passive
in nature because you're not advancing
your pawns
as far as it can go so danny you know
when you see a position like this you
see f3
do you think that what seemed promising
uh presented a sharp sicilian
might turn into more of a positional
battle how do you think max team is
going to handle this
the move order is interesting you talk
about it i'm someone who plays this
structure
often with white uh obviously talking
talking about that
pretty much whenever i have an
opportunity to in these broadcasts when
sharp sicilians are played we don't get
that opportunity as often as i'd like
now that i think about it
but the the whole point of the structure
of course is is to
try to launch these english attacking
ideas over here on the king side
now with e6 being played so this is the
more flexible structures you set the the
advantage of it is it keeps control over
the center
you have options and often you will look
to be a little more aggressive with the
d5 move
in these sicilians but as you said it's
a little bit tamer the lines are less
forcing i'm actually not surprised to
see e6 because
i think at this point he might be asking
carol what type of english attack he
wants to get and now the hand has been
a little bit more revealed with bishop
e3 but we'll see white white can do a
number of different things now
queen 32 and castles long is the most
straightforward way to play
um but also in some of these positions
white can look to get going with g4
and even g5 before you commit the the
the king's position i know that sounds
crazy would you ever castle short after
g4 g5 well
one of the advantages of the structure
is because you're you haven't actually
committed
fully yet if b5 is played early you
might see an a4 strike and the idea is
to undermine the queen side pawns
create some positional mess over here
for black before you've actually fully
committed
where you want to put the king so okay
b5 is played now this will be
interesting to see
i i'm guessing we're going to see queen
d2 instead of the g4 idea
and part of the reason is because of the
a4 move order that's now
a flexible option for white because
black has played b5 right away
um but okay g4 g4 is also very
very straightforward this is more the uh
i guess sometimes
the perennial variation is something
where white and would play a move order
like this
with bishop e3 e6 and then g4 without f3
and this idea you're actually going for
g4 g5 and then f4 in one move
rather than wasting the f3 tempo here
with b5 played
um you know there's a there's so many
different ways this game could go at
this point
i'm excited to see what kind of prep
alex cenko has here against uh
against envelopes night or yeah and
an interesting question as well but this
is getting a little bit deeper and we
you know we see all the games on screen
but is if white plays g4 and not if
really when white plays g4
will black play h6 or leave the pawn on
h7
and then kind of ensure that your knight
is going to get kicked off of the f6
square which is very common so
blacks knights often go knight b to d7
knight to b6 is
one of the main ideas and uh when white
plays g4 are you gonna meet that with
h6 or uh just allow that g5 push to kick
the knight so
one of the central themes of such a
position it seems like alexander grishok
by the way has finally
reached his board and is making moves so
he's worried for a second that
he might not show one of the sidelines
here on the
sideline stories that we've been sort of
handling in the background everybody is
whether alexander grisham will show up
at his board um and he has
and so that's fantastic news for
everybody
well we've uh we've got this english
attack just developing
against mvl this move order with the
knight coming to d7 is
uh important for black in the sense that
you're more ready than ever
to deal with the g4 g5 ideas for example
if this
is gone for now you can play knight to
b6 and after
the move g5 you get the knight behind
the other knight on b6 and this is kind
of the ideal setup
neither neither pony is stepping on each
other's toes over here on the queen side
and note that the delayed development of
the bishop on e7 means that you're a few
tempe up queen c7 bishop e7 rook c8
black is looking to fully focus on the
queen side rather than develop the king
side and get castle so
that's one of the key points of putting
the knight on d7 rather than emphasizing
a move that may seem natural to people
looking at it bishop e7 or bishop b7
knight bd7 is a very accurate uh
approach for black often
in this in this early b5 advance but
again okay he plays a3 now this is
interesting because i was going to say
one of the things is white can go for
variations that you don't always think
about
in an english attack structure here and
be a little more aggressive but instead
plays for a3
wow an nbl immediately strikes with h5
now trying to slow down
uh white's pawn storm so it kind of says
an eye for an eye you slow down my
natural sicilian idea of b4
and i'm going to make sure you it's a
little bit harder for you to advance on
the king side as well
yeah and this a3 move was already
relatively rare danny you have
a very good grasp on these positions g4
the most
common followed by castle's queen side
and then after a3
h5 is a move that i can only see being
played
one time uh in the past or a couple of
times really
uh and then by transposition we've you
know have several games in this line
but um the pawn on h5 stops your g4 move
so it kind of tames white's approach
but it has a risky side to it as well
because when you play h5 you are gonna
have a harder time figuring out what to
do with this king on e8 because castling
kingside
which already is dangerous now feels
even more dangerous when you've extended
this pawn so far so that's just
something to keep
in the back of your mind is where is
this king going to go for black or is
this going to stay in the center because
it is hard to get to as black
pieces are nicely centralized and
focused
um really on going to the queen side
where white's king likely is going to go
to so
those are some dynamics to position one
of the one of the things we've been
curious to see is what kind of prep alex
senko
will bring to the table let's talk a
little bit about the young man he is
the youngest competitor in the entire
competition the wild card
from russia 22 years of age and
a brighton shining star for the future
of russia's chess but he's going up
against maxine vashey legrov
the frenchman with three names who
hardly needs an introduction
sometimes sometimes needs to shave
sometimes not so uh he's uh rocking a
beard there
and our uh and our video video card
profile the guy is uh got a huge
pedigree
one of the favorites to maybe win this
entire event and can't wait to see what
he comes up with here is black so
real quick we're gonna move on to the
next games but uh
this is this is gonna be one to keep in
mind this is kind of what i was hoping
for robert alexenko going
right at mvl's wheelhouse saying i'm not
afraid let's get a super sharp game
and nbl therefore getting you know what
ends up happening is
is it creates winning chances for both
sides in that process right
so this is going to be a sharp one for
sure the only thing i'm concerned about
right now for lexanko is the fact that
he's moving
a little bit cautiously in terms of his
time management
mvl blitzing out his opening just like
yesterday and alexianco
it just has that feel of somebody who's
not quite certain
maybe didn't expect this from maxim
and now that's making me a little bit
nervous on his behalf just because
we have seen him get in time trouble in
previous rounds we had him
for an interview yesterday and he said
his openings need some work
and especially with the black pieces now
he has the white pieces and he needs to
make the most of it because he's had
three blacks and one white thus far
okay and that's a that's a vintage relay
error
i almost like came out of my chair there
and said because i almost said mouse
slip and then i'm like wait dan this is
not an
online event there are no mouse slips at
the board so this is a
a relay error from the live dgt
transmission
clearly they uh it has been fixed now
and and everything is okay king d1 was
not played bishop b7 immediately
responded to
let's check in on the other games robert
um the one that is
maybe maybe moved furthest along to me
is kind of our our prime time matchup
between yonder pontiac and wong hao
um let's uh let's bounce over there and
see that wow we have our first
reference to uh to the alpha zero push
the h pawn of the day
immediately on the board here h4 played
by yon napomniashi and
we talked a lot about these ideas
yesterday with the influence
of neural nets and how they look at some
of these otherwise equal
middle games with an opportunity to just
well might as well push this pawn
and create some long-term attacking
chances that maybe spice things up on
the king side even if not
immediately uh leading to a kingside
attack so
i like this move immediately we should
probably back up and look at the opening
but i like it
yeah and actually it looks like a
exchange french defense
and this is the second time in this
tournament that we've said that because
when
wong hao was black against alexander
grishock they also had the same pawn
structure before things changed
but um out of this opening there's a
petrol but
yeah you know i know what the opening
was but it ha it looks like an exchange
french
right it has the same exact pawn
structure when you go e takes d5
and black goes e takes d5 so you trade
your e pawns
in a different manner in this game but
the same exact pawn structure arises
so we get this exact structure as
robert's talking about where there's
only one open file at least to start all
things focused on
the e-file rookie one castles knight bd2
okay this is
uh these positions i think always just
look
look rather tame like what's really
going to happen here in a completely
symmetrical position
it's very different for example from the
the open sicilian we're seeing between
alexenko and maxine bacher the grav but
it doesn't mean that there aren't a lot
of winning chances and just a different
type
of of area to misstep right when you're
calculating a sicilian robert
often you have to get deep in those
lines because it's a race right it's
like i go there he goes there you're
kind of calculate constantly what tempe
arrive first
and these types of positions you're
always looking for a way to swindle that
very very small edge you see that the
eval bar says white has because you're
hoping in the end of some of the smoke
that you end up being the one with
control over the only open file
or you know the first person to start
gaining some critical
tempe so it's a different kind of game i
like this move h4 because you're
basically just
throwing upon a little bit of caution to
the wind and seeing how black handles
that when white already has a little bit
more control over the critical area here
in the center
yeah and i mean the pawn can't be
captured that's the first thing that we
should point out because
bishop takes h4 now you see that the
queen on d8
it's overloaded protecting the bishop on
h4 and the knight on d6
so you can just capture the bishop on h4
the queen will capture and you lose your
knight
on d6 that's a problem so this is not a
blunder of a pawn or anything like that
it does gain some important space on the
king side
because in a symmetrical position you
need to figure out if you're playing for
an advantage and not just equality you
know how are you going to press your
opponent where are some of the
weaknesses well right
position doesn't really have any
structural weaknesses for black
but some of the pieces feel a little bit
iffy for instance the knight on a6
that's not really
the square you want it to be on and the
knight may try to reroute itself via
c7 to e6 but when you have an open file
and the e file is the lone open file
your rooks
want to get onset file white has a rook
on e1
already nicely placed there black the
rook on f8 the rook on a
they might want to do the same but with
this bishop on e7 your kind of pieces
are cramping your rook's uh style in a
sense
and so it's not so easy for black to
find an ideal setup whereas white's
pieces feel much more naturally placed
you know and it seems again like i love
the way you describe it because you know
it's very
symmetrical black has no structural
weaknesses all these things are true
but because of the you combine two
things right the fact that black is down
just a little bit of time right it's
just a temperature two
but that temperature two if it allows
white to establish a pawn on h6
maybe it allows h5 and even just knight
g3 where you start looking at these
knights hopping into f5 and e5 squares
there is this sort of outside potential
that white quickly swings
everything to the king's side for an
attack right and and so you have to be
careful of that
despite the symmetry of the position
there are some potential dangers
not exactly the type of attacking
position that we have in the alex cenko
mvl game but
we'll keep an eye on it just like we had
to keep an eye on our competitors
and uh and everything that uh that they
bring to the candidates tournament
these guys pedigrees are long we remind
you of this every day who they are
and some of their some of their greatest
chess accomplishments yonda pomnyashi
uh you know maybe maybe one of the most
talented players in his generation this
guy is an absolute wild card i think if
he got to the world championship match
against magnus carlson
it'd be super interesting to see what
he's capable of he's a former second of
magnus carlson
would that play into things i think a
lot of people have questions about
what this guy could do but he's going up
against wong hao
robert this guy won a tournament known
as the chess.com fide grand swiss at the
isle of man
um what i hear is he felt like you
competing in that event gave him good
luck
so there's that only so many players can
use that as their calling card and for
wong hao
a really impressive performance in the
isle of man
impressive start here it feels like he's
in the
prime form of his career i'm very happy
to see it i'm a huge fan of his as a
chess player
and well he does have his work cut out
for him in this game he has played
knight to c7 so he is going on the
rerouting and whoa we've seen an
important decision
just take place because wow h4 was a
novelty by young
and the point of it was in one hand to
maybe support a pawn thrust all
throughout the board
but also helped a nice journey to attack
the king side
and an immediate trade on g5 so that you
deal with the checkmate threat of queen
takes h7 a mate
but you don't have to maybe compromise
some of the squares around your king if
you play g6
those dark squares around the king can
feel a little bit vulnerable
so he decides just to chop that pony
kick it off the board
and after bishop takes g5 which i think
will be played because h takes g5
96 feels like you're allowing black to
um
head those knights towards the king side
the g5 pawn it looks good and since
it opens the h file but you have to
remember you've already castled
so yeah if you had not castled a rook on
h1 would stare down
at the h7 pawn but because you have
castle maybe just creating an
unnecessary weakness
whereas bishop takes g5 keeps the pawn
structure intact there it's been played
and now forces black's hand into maybe
playing with like f6
which then creates other weaknesses like
the square e6 a long
term idea but i think a deep one
and one that i'm really coming to
appreciate for yamaha machine
yeah this is super interesting because
if you just look even more concretely
right f6 is a move that
as you said weakens e6 slows down the
remaneuvering of the knight
but if you don't play f6 what are you
doing right if you put the queen on d7
is there is there rookie seven just
immediately on the spot if the queen
moves to some other square
is bishop e7 a move i mean immediately
forking the rook on f8 and the knight on
d6 so
i think okay so f6 actually has to be
played and it just was
and here comes the bishop back to f4 so
you know interesting i think i was
suffering from a little bit of hangover
bias here with this h4 move talking
about yesterday's games where a
hangover bias of yesterday's games don't
smile
for no other reason than that um you saw
my reaction so quickly you're like
robert driving the h-pawn up the board
to h6 is this alpha zero idea we talked
a lot
about with vishy and nan on the show
yesterday so i wasn't even really
thinking about the fact that it was
obviously also an anchor for the night
and in hindsight now the fact that white
has managed to
force black to get rid of the dark
square bishop and
uh and then plays knight g3 anyway i
know the position is
roughly equal but from a practical
perspective
i like uh i like what napomnioshi's
doing with only his second chance with
the white pieces here
through the first five games yeah and
you know when we think about
evaluations you say roughly equal i know
you're not doing this but
when you see an engine it people think
oh i can relax
no this is actually the type position
where you can't relax because
black needs to come up with some idea
whether that's play rookie 8 and trade
some rooks
you need to think about the bigger
picture what pieces do you want to
exchange
what squares really need protecting or
what squares are
is it okay to have them seem weak
because white's not actually going to be
able to infiltrate
so the f5 square is a great question can
i allow
black actually white to capture on d6
which is
one of the threats and then put the
knight on f5 and that helps white
get the e7 square attack the g7 square
is that really something that adds value
to white's position
or is that just something that i need to
keep in the back of my mind but not
fear so the reason why i say like that
is
should black play move like g6 now which
takes away the f5 square
pretty permanently but allows for the h6
square to be occupied by the white
bishop or pawn h5
to chisel at that pawn structure on
black's king's side
so these are the very important
decisions and considering that jan has
come well prepared
he's moving instantly if i am wong hao
i'm really just trying to figure out not
just this move because you know you
don't want to play chess on a move by
move
basis you want to come up with plans and
right now is a critical moment deciding
do i allow a knight to come to f5 or do
i immediately play move like g6 which
has
other concessions in the position yeah
and if that knight gets to f5
you know does it lead to more potential
attacks right queen sliding over you
start looking at the g7 square
h5h6 or ideas that are still on the
agenda so
you see just a lot of shuffling
yeah i mean playing on because if anyone
was better it was him he had the better
structure pawns connected with one
another now we're in a rook end game
that is very easily drawn
uh but for dingley wren it's a good
result
a solid game with the black pieces for
alexander grishok the
frustration must continue to mount now
this game in particular
drawing digging around that's fine but
just how that his tournament has gone
where he was fortunate to survive
in round four and in rounds one through
three he had the
superior position in all three games and
he did not make the most of his chances
and then when he goes and looks at yon
naponshi okay
three and a half and a five a relay
error
this one has to be a relay error i just
jumped out of my seat
you're talking no i didn't mean to
interrupt you with my scared but i you
know
oh i'm looking at it now rook to b6
yeah i've always thought okay this has
to be a relay or the move has to be rook
to b5 everybody the move
certainly was rook to b5 to attack the
e5 pawn i guess even rook b7 is probably
also okay
the one move that loses in this position
the only move that loses is rook to b6
and that's what the uh
that's what the ggt relayed but it's
been fixed okay
by the way that was the only move that
lost in one move not every time you say
that and it's actually true
yep no this position the only losing
move for white was rook b6 and that's
what the dgt
accidentally slipped well
it's funny because we've had these dgt
uh
issues today and that's why i thought
rook f2 was played by anish
and earlier yeah right because rook f2
made so much sense and
what i was going to say was that grishok
he's going to look and see
how jan is playing and he's like i could
have more points myself i was better
against yon with the black pieces i was
better
against wong hao with the white pieces
against alexienko
carrillo had some great defense to save
that game but i was the one pressing
so where are your victories going to
come from every single
player in this field is a tenacious
defender
and at a certain moment you just need to
score victories nothing else
matters when in an event like this it's
win or go home because
you know you get some money for second
place that's great i don't want to
dismiss that but really what every
single player
in this field is i want to win first
place so i can play for the world
championship title
well i mean on that note they get the
exact same money
or no matter what place they finish oh
is that true in the candidates yeah
the total price fund is actually split
evenly amongst the eight players
um and it's one of the things that uh
is so what you said is not only do they
get money for second place they get
money for eighth place they get the same
money no matter what the total price
fund is split
divided equally so the only prize that
matters in this event
is the world chess championship title
opportunity
is that true that that's what i believe
is true
according to the rules yeah um
and that's uh that's what our our uh
prizes graphic which was prepared by the
official rules so
i'm pretty sure that's the case uh
i i don't know right i think players
just with the same score split
points with the prizes but why would
every player get the same prize
oh i just i just misread that graphic
then that was just me
you're right i'm wrong as usual
don't ever speed read everybody this is
a really good lesson so i'm
i'm a lo i'm a walking example of that
um
so the players do not always with the
prize fun the players split the prize
fund evenly with all those at their same
score so there is no like tie break
thing
same money for every score robert
don't robert me at the end here it
wasn't my mistake
[Laughter]
robert don't you know where the prizes
work
you went full dad mode on me there at
the end you know trying to be
conversational and then like
put all of the onus on me as if i did
something other than
just speak correctly so thank you for
that
daniel i appreciate when you get the
information
incorrectly
oh man you know at least we're having a
good time right
you can always a ball always choose to
have fun no matter what
even though the uh the last game
remaining not going to give us a lot of
fireworks here
we'll see how long grishik decides to
push it out but um
the story of the round the story of the
tournament yonda pomnyashi right
if we want to uh remind anybody who may
just be joining us he is the only person
to get a to get a w this round he's uh
the only person rocking a man bun though
not in that video interview there but uh
he's he's just played amazing chess so
far
we're not quite halfway through the
tournament yet but yonda pomnyashi
did get a victory over wong hao there
will be a video
review of that game on all of our
platforms later today
youtube twitch i think we've even been
putting them right on chess.com if
you're into that so
uh check out john's victory over wong
hao if you happen to miss it later but
i mean at this point go ahead it's over
they drew
oh okay there you go they drew
well the uh final scores are as you see
them
uh right there below you we are updating
the grisha dingley red one but that's
right in front of you so not hard to see
uh three draws one victory yonda
pomnyashi is the only man
to take it home this was a this was a
wild round
five um some weird feelings i felt like
we were we were
close to several decisive results the
alex senko game with maxine vashey the
grav anishigiri with thought
of caruana for sure there was a missed
opportunity but
all right um we're going to take a very
very our last and final break
don't go anywhere get our final thoughts
we're gonna preview tomorrow's round six
remind you of the pairings that are up
our head
get robert's thoughts on what he thinks
is in store with those matchups
and our uh final review round five of
the 2020 feta candidates in just a
couple of minutes
[Music]
so
and we are back here with our final
recap of what was an exciting day here
round five from the 2020 feed a
candidates
has the pomnyashi standing atop the
leaderboard for the first time in the
event we have a clear leader
and uh three and a half out of five he's
played just fantastic chess to this
point
i don't even know what else to say
besides i'm i'm super
super excited to see where the back half
of this tournament takes to pomnyashi as
well as now
for the first time we have only one
person in second place right
uh with three out of five that's vashey
legrov
yeah jan has earned his spot atop the
leaderboard
maxime we had it on for an interview he
was pleased with his play
his preparation was stellar for cruella
alexianco you see him in eighth place
but he's really tied
sixth through eighth and that can change
in a single game he gets a win all of a
sudden he leapfrogs some of his
competitors but
uh not great preparation from alexenko
clearly stopped
too early and maxime had it all worked
out and
well you know he's a little disappointed
he couldn't drum up some more play and
score victory but when you're the black
piece against a super strong grandmaster
that's you know pretty much the best you
can hope for and uh
who will play magnus carlson for the
world championship still a question
that remains uh unanswered as we have
nine rounds remaining
i think the biggest uh sort of shocker
disappointment
sort of leaving you unfulfilled of the
round was anish geary's inability
to convert on fabiano caruana when he
when he had a
clearly borderline winning position but
maybe maybe tomorrow he writes the ship
alex cenko once again gets the white
pieces against anishigiri so two whites
in a row for the young man who's had
the majority of blacks up until this
point aneesh giri
sorry to interject there danny but i was
going to say this is a dangerous game
for geary
because if he if he hopes to score a
victory against lexenko
you just can't will it into into
existence you couldn't ask for a better
position than he got today
and that advantage dissipated very
quickly and alexianco is dangerous
he is super talented do not take him for
granted
alexander grisha continues to uh to
fight to get his first victory he hasn't
lost he hasn't won tomorrow
sasha gets the white pieces against
fabian or karwana
uh speaking of a man who's still also
struggling to kind of find his form
right bobby has both won
a game in this event he's lost a game in
this event
i mean is it fair to say at this point
now that i'm reviewing all five in my
head
he's had some of the most volatile
positions in the event as far as
kind of just getting by and also of
course having both won and lost games
clearly there's some volatility there so
you know carwana trying to find his form
grisha maybe with the white pieces
uh we'll get his first victory tomorrow
and it's interesting because grishok
gets double whites he just
played against england around with the
white pieces fabiano gets double blacks
he just played anishikiri with black
today and caruana you're absolutely
correct he started off well
with a good position against maxine
vashira grav with black they ended up
drawing
he beat carrillo lexianco a fantastic
preparation
job that led to a precise finish
and then he did not play that well
against
dingley wren long line of preparation
didn't work out for him and since then
it's been nothing but
kind of iffy chess so fabiano needs to
right the ship i'm not sure if playing
alexander grishok is the recipe
that he desires speaking of playing well
against dingley ren though yana pomnyach
is going to need to do that tomorrow
he's obviously uh been playing the best
chess overall of anybody in the event
the scoreboard says so he's leading the
tournament with three and a half out of
five
but i mean now that he gets another
another chance at white i would not want
to be in dingley ren's shoes tomorrow
i'll tell you that
right this guy is is just he's playing
some of the best chess i've ever seen
him play
uh honestly if we're talking about
napomnyayashi and uh
i expect it to continue he he took down
wong hao
dingley runs countrymen today and uh
he'll try to do the same tomorrow versus
dingley wren speaking of taking down
wong hao there's our game report
overall uh only one mistake that defined
the game which is amazing you look at
the accuracy level basically completely
the same for both players besides the
one blunder there
a little bit of a strange evaluation
actually for them both to be given the
same accuracy when one player lost
i wonder how that works we'll talk we'll
look into that but definitely queen d7
you and i spent a lot of time analyzing
it
was the one blunder wong how needed but
i don't think that takes anything away
from nepo's win robert in fact if
anything it almost makes it more scary
like i said his victory was magnus
carlson-esque
it was never really that impressive but
he just kept grinding and poking and
poking
and then one blunder queen to d7 toss
wong how the game
it did indeed and for yon upon nishi a
well played game
it showed his technique as he did in the
first round so
jan should be happy guang hao
unfortunately for him he suffers his
first defeat and he gets
the white pieces tomorrow against maxime
vasher legrov
and is that a you know is that the
making of a comeback for wong hao
i'm not so sure maxime showed very good
preparation
today with the black pieces and
something of note though
is maxim also gets a second black in a
row
so dingley wren fabiano caruana and
maxine vashila grav both just got double
blacked in rounds five and six
and that's how things even themselves
out when you have this sort of double
round robin with players chasing each
other it's an odd
it seems like an odd occurrence but the
differences in these events versus like
a swiss event that people are aware of
or some sort of random arena pairing all
the pairings are done way in advance so
they already know
everybody will get the same colors uh i
mean
obviously everyone will get both white
and black against each opponent so how
that balances out
is not unfair in that sense necessarily
but it can lead to some momentum which
is kind of what we're talking about here
naponnayashi
we talked about it yesterday robert when
he got through the first four rounds
with three out of four blacks
we knew that it was going to be really
dangerous for people that he was playing
that well and hadn't even had a great
chance with white yet
um and so now maxine getting another
chance with black we'll see how he holds
up but
the full schedule let's remind you we'll
be back at it again tomorrow
it is monday march 22nd
round six is on sorry march 23rd today
is march 22nd lol
4 am i i have been up since then um
and uh march 23rd we will be back at it
here with more candidates coverage
make sure you uh tune in don't go
anywhere shout out to just
huge audiences we had today we love you
so much thank you for all the support
everywhere and uh the uh
i think i think the fans really enjoyed
vidigrathi thanks to our guest right
that guy was awesome
a lot of fun especially for you
oh yeah i cannot wait until vin and i
take on you and anish i don't know when
that's happening
but we're already we're getting the
wheels rolling here we're ready
we gotta we gotta talk about it i mean i
gotta get a niche on board you know
um we've already chatted a little bit
about it but like he said he's not
really thinking about anything until the
feed day candidates tournament is done
so uh hopefully he'll be thinking about
great things after it and ready
ready to throw down an event like this
but um anyway
again huge thanks to everybody all of
our subscribers all of our premium
members you guys make this happen
thank you so much on behalf of the team
here a lot of people working hard behind
the scenes huge thanks to peter dockers
all the reports and uh opening
contributions he makes that end up
finding their way into the news report
so make sure you check out those
the production crew all of our
moderators and everybody here
at chess.com we love you robert loves
you call him
his number is 555 say yes to hess
555 say yes to hess
robert has his number i just gave it out
live on
on air here and we will see you tomorrow
with more candidates coverage
[Music]
do
you